faire demi tour désolé ce chauffeur
devra prendre son mal en patience
depuis 5 heures ce matin plus aucun
camion ne rentre chez psa hérimoncourt
une cinquantaine de salariés ont décidé
de bloquer l'entrée de l'usiné une
manière pour eux de montrer leur
opposition à la fermeture programmée du
site
nous on a déjà bloqué dix camions depuis
4 heures ce matin donc en aucun cas il
ya aucun camion qui rentre il veut leur
montrer donc notre mécontentement
donc il ya eu aucune production non plus
de fait donc là on est toutes tous et
toutes sur la tournée donc la petite
tournée où il ya le moins de monde
et puis à 13h la grosse tournée va
arriver justement pour avoir un peu plus
de soutien qu'on soit plus nombreux sur
le site une grève surprise qui pourrait
durer toute la journée et qui vise à
mettre la pression sur la direction à
deux jours d'une réunion cruciale pour
l'avenir du site et de ses 200 emplois